well time to eat crow boys i was wrong
and you were right
the youtube comment section for once in
your life give yourselves a big round of
applause
everybody who's been skeptical of bill
gates this whole time i bet you're
giving yourself uh
just take a victory lap okay you you get
this one these new
allegations coming out on bill gates are
so crazy and it made me realize that um
i've been giving this guy a pass for too
long based on his philanthropy work
which has laundered his reputation and
ingratiated himself to a lot of people
including myself
who kind of saw him as just this lovable
grandpa
uh yeah that turned out to be uh kind of
a bunch of
a bunch of nonsense as we'll find out in
a second here but here's me
i said bill gates is cancelled and
basically it's a piece defending bill
gates and say you guys got him all wrong
he's a lovable
philanthropist how far how much i have
changed in the last six months boys how
much i have soured
on bill gates let me tell you uh it's
all because of the epstein stuff
watching this epstein case come out and
watching bill gates repeatedly lie
over and over again it made me realize
there's not a good piece
documenting these lies just lie after
lie after lie
after lie after lie and because it was
what convinced me to take a
second look on all billy boy i thought
i'd share it with you because
you might not be aware of how much bill
gates has
lied and tried to basically
underplay his relationship with epstein
arguably
the worst person of the 21st century the
worst
billionaire
[Laughter]
now i'm not making this video saying all
the comments saying that he's
microchipping people i'm not saying
y'all are right
but what i am saying is that bill gates
he's not a lovable grandpa
no actually he was friends with for as
long as he possibly could be
until the pr just looked too bad for him
and then it seems like he uh
he tried to distance himself very poorly
and now it's cost him his marriage
and it may cost him his entire public
reputation
and we're going to talk about it right
now we know traditionally you hang out
with these kinds of people
chances are you got sticky fingers
somewhere so let's go
through the evidence we'll stick to the
epstein story because that's what's
interesting to me
in the latest fallout connected to
jeffrey epstein mit is opening an
investigation into its ties to the
financier and convicted sex offender
journal citing several people
reporting that one source of concern for
melinda a global advocate for women and
girls
was bill's dealings with convicted sex
offender jeffrey epstein he also has
one of the largest most established
foundations on his own
why would they ever set up a charitable
trust benefiting
jeffrey epstein so let's start this web
of lies with the first time it was
announced that bill gates may have had
something to do
with jeffrey epstein what did he say new
york times sheds light on the connection
between microsoft founder bill gates and
the late jeffrey epstein
after gates name came up in connection
with epstein
and mit media lab gates gave a statement
to the wall street journal where he
insisted
he did not have any business
relationship or friendship with epstein
all right so no no business relationship
or friendship you hear that
nothing this man's never seen the man
never met him but oops
it looks like uh the new york times
found an
email from bill gates talking about
epstein
the first time they met which is weird
because apparently they had never met
before but
he apparently praised epstein saying his
lifestyle is very different that's one
way to put it
and kind of intriguing that's really
weird although it would not work for me
mr gates emailed colleagues in 2011
after their first get together with mr
epstein now bear in mind of course
it's important to note it was known at
this time epstein's
misdoings he had already been charged
with solicitation of a minor so that's
really important this is after the fact
gates meets with them so okay
what do they do now at this point a
spokesperson from bill gates told the
times that
bill gates regrets ever meeting epstein
noting that was an
error in judgment to do so and at odds
with gates personal values so now
we're led to believe that maybe he only
met him one time
so okay here they make it sound like it
was just a one-off meeting
a chance meeting a mistake he never did
it again right
uh oops once again according to the new
york times gates actually met
at least three times in the guys
manhattan
townhouse uh once staying late into the
night does this sound like
somebody who's not your friend you know
you're hanging out with them all night
does this
this sound like a just a casual meeting
of the meeting of the minds
only three times guys only three times
well okay
so bill gates they go okay maybe we did
that
maybe we maybe we met with them more
than once
but hey i never went to florida with him
see according to a report from
uh the wall street journal this time we
hear from bill gates he says
i never look i may have seen him a few
times but
according to him i met him i didn't have
any business relationship or friendship
with him
i didn't go to new mexico or florida or
palm beach or any of that guys
but okay he says he's never been to
florida
right oops in a piece that is uh
actually defending bill gates we find
that bill gates has lied
once again see according to flight logs
gates flew on an aircraft of epstein's
once but this was to florida
this is the place that he said he's
never been ever been to florida
actually yes it turns out maybe we did
go to florida
hey maybe one time florida yes florida
yes
but what's the new lie oh mr gates
apparently
who owns his own 40 million dollar jet
hadn't been aware that it was mr
epstein's plane
this man serial serial liar here and he
continues to deny and minimize and i
i don't i don't know this guy never
never met him what who
this is the stuff that pisses me off and
has made me totally rethink this man but
that was where the story pretty much
lied until this bill and melinda gates
marriage uh kerfuffle as you guys
probably know
uh they got divorced very sad we don't
celebrate divorce here
so that's very sad to see but what has
come out of it
has been very interesting in the gates
epstein
relationship because several reports if
you've been following about bill gates
have come out
a lot of them with anonymous sources
which a lot of people are uncomfortable
with and i'll give you guys my take on
that
now before we go any further let me just
kind of lay where we are with you
with relation to the like what's been
happening because all this bad pr has
been coming out right after the divorce
and people are confused why
why why now where are these sources
coming from
well many people including myself
suspect the melinda gates pr
team of releasing this data or releasing
these sources sort of silently
there's a lot of kind of good reasons
for that i mean usually you s
in an acrimonious divorce like this you
may see them like both playing pr
games like if you go onto twitter right
now you'll find hundreds of people
talking about
melinda gates has the pr team royals
think they have
what are the odds melinda gates pr team
drops new pictures of bill gates and
epstein before the end of the month
most people are speculating that it's
that that divorce team
and that's actually why we're seeing
these reports come out
um here's sauger from the rising i think
they usually have good takes
they also kind of have this theory now
this is likely leaked from melinda gates
divorce team so take it with a grain of
salt
yeah it's probably is and i do think
that's worth saying that you probably do
need to take it with a grain
of salt but why do we think this well
it's because
these news outlets like the wall street
journal
the daily beast the new york times all
of them are running
massive bombshell stories with anonymous
sources
and you wouldn't run stories this big
against somebody as powerful as bill
gates unless the sources were really
good
as someone who sort of had to deal with
the problem of anonymous sources before
i've kind of had to grapple with like
how do you vet an anonymous source
for your audience and what you find out
is you actually sort of have to be
more careful with anonymous sources not
less careful because
if it turns out wrong and it turns out
that the anonymous source is lying
then it makes you look really bad it
makes you look horrible so
before doing this reporting my guess is
is that these
these papers did their due diligence and
they found out
okay they're from the inside scoop i
mean they have the inside story a lot of
them are citing it as like
people familiar with the matter okay
who's familiar with bill
and melinda gates marriage who's more
familiar
than melinda gates or someone a
spokeswoman from melinda gates
and they're never gonna come out and say
it out loud obviously for obvious
reasons it's a bad look
so instead it's sort of leaked to the
presses etc but with that context of
where
the these sources are coming from and
also uh
you should take it with a grain of salt
as well as realize that it probably is
coming from a source who probably does
know what they're talking about
let's talk about what they figured out
the biggest report comes from the daily
beast
saying jeffrey epstein gave bill gates
advice on how to end toxic marriage
sources say there's that sources say
again
i think it probably should be read
melinda says
it's just my my opinion purely my
speculation
uh there but what's really important
about this is once again we find out
that we've been
lied to again because what after years
of saying that they were not friends yes
they may have met three times yes they
may have you know stayed late
we now find out that the billionaire met
epstein
dozens of times which is many times more
than previously reported previously we
had like three to five times we were
thinking maybe several times
now we're hearing that it's dozens these
people were friends
they were close they hung out i mean
this is
such a bad look going from no
relationship at all now who is he
what epstein to to like their buds
they go hang out when bill's having a
hard time with melinda listen i don't
know about that part
what we do know is that they probably
were really close
everything we're seeing come out is
saying that they're much closer than
admitted
and everything we're saying hearing from
the bill gates side is just the constant
denial
but they've been denying everything from
the get-go so i don't put much stock
in what they're saying and one of the
massive bombshells to come out of this
is this part right here where gates
apparently
far from being unaware of uh epstein's
whole
problem with the law actually wanted to
help him
rehabilitate his image in the media
following his 2008 guilty plea sounds
like a real friend there
and discussed epstein becoming involved
with the bill
and melinda gates foundation to rehab
his minor for charge
like are you joking me that is such a
scumbag move and by the way
plays into a lot of explanations for
what we've been wondering for a very
long time because
everyone is naturally wondering when
they talk about you know
epstein and the gates connection because
we were always told well they were just
meeting for philanthropy the question
was
why what is gates you know this
billionaire magnate with the most
powerful people in the world
that he knows what does he need epstein
for but now
we might think that epstein might have
needed gates and gates might have
wanted to pay epstein a favor by getting
him involved in his philanthropy
to rehabilitate his image going back to
one of the earliest reports that we saw
at the very beginning
we kind of can close a loose end here
which was why
why were they ever involved as an
investigative reporter
why would gates say oh i had no
relationship with him
when of course he knows what you the
facts are so that's that always sets off
red flags for me
that's a great question why did bill
come repeatedly deny
his involvement relationship underplay
it because if it had all been truly
innocent if he'd only met
one time maybe even two times with
jeffrey epstein that would be easy to
admit to
and move on but if there's something
more sinister here
then all of his denials and repeated uh
you know kind of
down playing of their true relationship
would make sense
now beyond this honestly it just gets
into conspiracy land
and i don't want to go there i'm
interested in giving you the facts where
they lie right now
and telling you that we've been
repeatedly lied to by bill gates
and that this grandpa lovable
philanthropist image
may not be all it was said to be and i
wanted to get that to you i can't go any
further than that but you can be
sure you could be damn sure after being
made look like a fool
by bill gates because i defended him
beforehand and now i'm having to come
out and
report on this stuff you can be sure
that i'd be happy to report on news
stories as they come out i will tell you
i'll keep you in the loop
so if you're interested in this stuff
the life of the rich and powerful
subscribe smash like hit the bell
because when we learn more
i'll be the first to tell you about it
thanks for watching i hope you enjoyed
my maya culpa on bill gates i was wrong
the youtube comment section was right
and i can hardly believe it thanks for
watching and i'll see you in the next
[Music]
one